afc north receiver edition storylines
ravens we talked about them last segment
the fact that that the receiver position
they're not as involved as it may be
elsewhere
which top receiver free agents should
the ravens try to get
to accept their money and join their
team there's some good ones
out there all right here here's the two
that i mean of course hey listen we'd
love to see them get alan robinson or
chris godman
you know kenny gallaudet would be
amazing uh
do they were they gonna pay that type of
money though to me
those like those top three guys could
command you know
somewhere between 16 and 19 million
dollars a year i don't see the ravens
going that route right
the one guy that jumps off to me mike is
number
50. curtis samuel right there
to me you want to run the lamar jackson
offense
curtis samuel is the better
bigger version of hollywood brown he's
got
he's got two rockets up his butt he can
fly
he can play tailback he did it last year
when mccaffrey got hurt
they will toss him the ball and he will
run around the edge for an 80 yard
touchdown
you can give him the speed sweeps the
reverses to do all that
to me if you made me pick one that just
makes sense and i don't think he's gonna
be able to command a huge number
you know he's gonna get you have to pay
him but not like top right wide receiver
money
that was that's the one that just jumps
out to me when you talk about the ravens
and when you may have to do if you're
the ravens you're gonna have to sprinkle
a little more cash on probably
to convince a guy to come to a place
where he's taking
at best a leap of faith at worst he
signs on the dotted line and then
realizes things are no different than
they've been and i'm doing a lot of
blocking and
i'm really not getting to do the thing
that i want to do which is catch the
football that's the challenge and
you know until they can convince one of
these guys to sign on the draft is going
to be where they have to replenish
yeah that that position unless a guy
like a dez bryant stumbles into their
laps like he did last year but even he
doesn't want to play for him again
in 2021 he wants to play two more years
but for a team other than the ravens you
just don't see a lot of footballs flying
your way in that offense and they don't
need it odo beckham jr yeah
sorry no otto beckham jr recovering from
the acl
2021 browns or the field oh
man i mean it's the you know and for
full this is the first time we're seeing
these right so this
i just want to let everybody know it's
not like we had this at home last night
and i could do homework on these and i'm
not trying to make excuses
this is awesome you could have you could
have i could have i could have it was in
there
it wasn't there damn either way i'm good
it doesn't matter i'm gonna go with the
field
i don't know why they don't really need
to like they have
enough money to keep them and do all of
that
um but i don't know why i just have a
gut
feeling that he might be shopped around
quietly
this off season and there's some teams a
lot in the past like the new england
patriots
who have hide their eye on odell beckham
jr and things like that could use wide
receiver
i i don't know i have no feel or inside
info with this
at all i am intrigued where i want to go
like
hey that cleveland offense finally got
it going and
what it would have looked like with
odell beckham jr but i know you're gonna
go
well maybe they wouldn't have looked
like that if odell beckham jr was out
there and i i understand that question
i think it's fair i get it so i'm gonna
go the field what about you
here's the problem 14.5 million salary
this year
12.791 million of it is guaranteed for
injury
becomes fully guaranteed on march 19
which means it becomes fully guaranteed
they can't cut him
he can't pass a physical he's on the
team this year
at 14 and a half million with a million
dollar roster bonus that he gets when he
shows up for training camp
i think what will happen is this yeah
they bring him back they keep him on the
team
they see how it goes and then he's
potentially traded
at or before the deadline if it's not
working and if there's somebody else out
there that says hey you know what he is
healthy because that's the problem well
you're going to trade for this contract
if you don't know the guy's healthy and
ready to go in 2021 well you're you're
right but
there's there's two things i'll say
there just the the acl injury happened
at a decent time of the year to where i
would think there's no doubt he's ready
to go for the start of the season
and that money you're talking about for
a guy like odell beckham jr to me is
it's peanuts i think teams might look at
that and they can find ways to wiggle
that
in there they're going to go 12 14
million dollars whatever the hell the
number is they're gonna go well
i'll take it we'll go with it so that
that's where it's going to be
interesting and yeah i don't know
i'm really that that's going to be
something to watch here i think this
offseason
my guess is browns and then eventually
field before the tuesday after week 8
that he ends up being traded somewhere
because they're going to realize they
don't need him to make that offense go
yeah juju smith schuster
steelers of the field i'm going the
field all the way here
i will not even hesitate um first off
you know claypool and deontay johnson to
me
are better players than juju smith
schuster they bring more to the table as
far as their versatility their pure
explosiveness on the outside
juju is a guy that kind of needs to work
in the slot he's got great value
i'm not trying to say that you know but
he is a clear
real good number two and
you know he is a guy that will run block
and run over the middle and play physic
he's a big dude
you know and he is physical that way but
i just look at the steelers
and some of the issues they have with
their salary cap and everything like
that and i think they're pretty talented
the wide receiver position that i'm
saying field there
i agree with you as well even though
smith schuster said last week he wants
to retire with the steelers he wants his
legacy to be there i think someone else
is going to make him an offer the
steelers just won't yeah he can't
right they have to they have to be smart
with their dollars and this is a team
that has a high degree of confidence in
its ability to find receivers in the
draft
it has proven it time and again for more
than a decade
kevin colbert awesome job of finding
receivers in the draft
you can't pay anything close to market
value for juju smith schuster whatever
it's going to be
and and look i don't know who to
ultimately blame
for the corvette corvette stuff last
year and the browns is the browns but
they misplayed that they allowed him to
become a distraction they allowed his
words and his actions to motivate the
opponents
and i just feel like it's at a point
where the steelers are better off moving
forward
chris yeah i i hear that too i i'm i'm
with you um
you know i i think he's a really good
guy of course i don't think he does it
within you know
malice or mean or trying something
somebody's gotta talk to you but i know
you gotta talk to him say you're not
being mean but it's it's not helping but
it's not helping the cause exactly right
you know he's he's a social media star
i mean what damn he had a verizon uh
commercial
in the super bowl when he's riding a
giant sea creature i don't know and it
ate something right i mean that just
tells you
you know my little boy knows juju smith
schuster more through
social media and video games and he does
more through the what he does on the
football field
and i think he got a little too you know
obsessed with that aspect of his life
and everything like that
give me one name that would be the best
receiver gift for joe burrow
and the cincinnati bank oh oh man i mean
they're not they're not
agency or the draft well the receiver
you know
receiver wise they're not in a bad spot
they got a little talent there
you know they can go a lot of different
ways there you know i just look at guys
like hey the corey davises the marvin
jones the kenny gollidays
the bengals have some money to spend
certainly
you know i i look at all of those and
you know maybe you can even get a t-y
hilton who doesn't want to like
totally break the bank or something like
that add a little veteran presence to
some of those young receivers you got
there
uh so i'll be itching i would like them
to be better at past protecting him more
than anything
that would be the big thing i mean man
did he make you know
chicken salad out of chicken you know
what a lot last year
um all right and i agree with you they
need to protect him better especially
after the way he got injured and he
takes
a pounding they need to work on him they
need to nudge him gently to get him to
protect himself a little bit better
maybe he learned his lesson
last year when he suffered that injury
because that is not college football
that hit that he took
it was violent it was brutal and here's
hoping he's a hundred percent when the
regular season rolls around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports